mag der fraktion und wir kommen genau
richtig denn jedes gerade der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt aufgerufen worden ein
nicht ganz unwichtiger es geht um den
gleichlautenden gesetzentwürfe von ampel
fraktionen und der bundesregierung für
das steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 aydan
özoguz die bundestags-vizepräsidentin
hat in dieser sekunde den
tagesordnungspunkt tatsächlich
aufgerufen drei punkte vielleicht noch
den kürzeren die es hier geht der
grundfreibetrag bei der einkommensteuer
soll zeigen gesteigen die
pendlerpauschale soll steigen und auch
der arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag das alles
rückwirkend und wir beginnen mit der
debatte
damen und herren wir haben in der
letzten woche
in der zweiten und dritten lesung die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage beschlossen
in dieser sitzungswoche jetzt gerade
beraten wer über das
steuerentlastungsgesetz in zweiter und
dritter lesung und in der nächsten woche
haben wir die zweite und dritte lesung
für das feature corona hilfe
steuergesetz und das energie
steuersenkungsgesetz wir bringen in
diesen wochen die parlamentarischen
beratung zur umsetzung unserer
entlastungs pakete zum abschluss
insgesamt entlasten wir die bürgerinnen
bürger um 44 milliarden euro das kann
sich wirklich sehen lassen
und meine damen und herren wir werden im
herbst das thema kalte progression
angehen um weiter gegen den
inflationsdruck vorzugehen das kann ich
jetzt hier schon ankündigen bei dem
steuerentlastungsgesetz haben wir jetzt
drei zentrale leistungspunkte die
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages
bei der einkommensteuer um 200 auf
1200 euro das ist die erste erhöhung
seit elf jahren seit 2000 erhält man
fragt sich wirklich was die vorgängerin
in den letzten acht jahren gemacht hat
wir haben den grundfreibetrag um 363
euro an das ist die absolut höchste
betrag in 18 jahren auch da tun wir das
was die vorgängerregierung vielleicht
längst hätte tun können und wir ziehen
die anhebung der ferne pendlerpauschale
auf 38 cent vor und das alles
rückwirkend zum ersten januar 2022 das
bedeutet eine volle jahreswirkung von
viereinhalb milliarden euro der
entlastung insgesamt 18 milliarden euro
in dieser legislaturperiode
und neben diesen drei konkreten
entlastungsmaßnahmen beraten wir heute
auch der die energiepreis pauschale in
höhe von 300 euro den kinderbonus in
höhe von 100 euro zusätzlich zum
kindergeld das sind noch einmal zwölf
milliarden euro und zwar an gezielten
entlastung nicht mit der gießkanne wir
helfen den menschen mit direkten
zahlungen in den ersten entlastungspaket
die unterstützung brauchen und den
lasten parallel auch die breite mitte
unserer gesellschaft
und zwar über die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die energiepreis pauschale
die steuersenkung auf kraftstoffe dass
neun euro ticket und auch die
rentenerhöhung zu über 50 6% in diesem
sommer wird eine entsprechende
entlastung bringen wir werden uns aber
auch ehrlich machen wir machen uns
ehrlich wir können nicht alle
entwicklungen was die energiepreise
angeht auf dem weltmarkt ausgleichen mit
entsprechenden entlastungsmaßnahmen und
auch wenn man die ergebnisse der
steuerschätzung heute sich
vergegenwärtigt haben wir sehr sehr
viele unsicherheiten entwicklung der
energiepreise lieferketten probleme
auswirkungen auf darauf auf die
weltmarktpreise und inflation die guten
zahlen von heute werden uns keine
spielräume für neue ausgaben projekte
geben denn wir werden im herbst uns
darauf konzentrieren müssen dass wir die
kalte progression angehen und genau das
ist das was diese koalition macht auf
der einen seite die leistungsfähigkeit
des staates im auge haben damit wir
wieder zu einer art haushalts und
finanzpolitischen normalität in den
nächsten jahren kommen können das haben
wir nämlich seit 2009 10 wenn wir uns
alle ehrlich machen nicht mehr gesehen
und auf der anderen seite entlasten wir
da wo wir tun können und werden
natürlich auch sicherlich in den
nächsten jahr gucken dass wir
entsprechende anreize für
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen auf
den weg bringen wir fangen jetzt an mit
dem vierten steuer hilfe gesetzt wo wir
die degressive afa auch mit 20 22
einführen werden wir werden im nächsten
jahr die super abschreibung auf den weg
bringt für klimaschutz und digitale
wirtschaftsgüter und so wird es ein
vernünftiger schritt wo wir auf der
einen seite entlasten auf der anderen
seite die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres
landes vor augen haben und vor augen
haben und da kann ich sie nur alle
herzlich einladen hier uns zu
unterstützen der dreisprung an
entlastungen den wir jetzt auf den weg
bringen ist zielgerichtet für kleine und
mittlere einkommen
wir werden die bürgerinnen und bürger
und die unternehmen in milliarden höhe
entlasten
ich danke ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
und mit dem zustimmen
denn und darauf gilt es auch hinzuweisen
die jesus steuerentlastungsgesetz soll
auch nachher noch verabschiedet werden
zwei nach der zweiten und dritten lesung
also es geht auf die zielgerade und dann
kann das auch relativ bald realität
werden das ganze wie gesagt rück werten
teilweise ins jahr 2022 hinein am pult
ist olav gutting aus der unionsfraktion
ist nun die regierung
endlich tätig geworden und lebt hier ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz vor nur leider
erreicht dieses gesetz überhaupt nicht
die selbst gesteckten ziele
es ist ein schlecht gemachtes gesetz um
7 der fdp wissen dass auch wenn sie sich
ehrlich machen wollen es ist ein
schlechtes gesetz obwohl es viereinhalb
milliarden euro kostet und ich sage
ihnen auch warum die anhebung des
grundfreibetrages fällt viel zu niedrig
aus die inflation aus dem jahr 2022
haben sie hier überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt und sie haben vor allem
vergessen den tarifverlauf anzupassen
das führt dazu dass wir eine stauchung
im anfangs bereich des tarifs haben
damit kommt es zu erheblichen
verwerfungen beim einkommensteuertarif
und diese maßnahme erzeugt einen noch
steileren anstieg des tarifverlaufs in
der ersten progressionszone sie schaffen
ist damit dass noch weniger anreize
bestehen eine beschäftigung im
niedriglohnbereich anzunehmen der bund
der steuerzahler hat errechnet dass von
der mindestlohn erhöhung zu beginn
dieses jahres knapp 50 prozent in
abgaben und steuern beim start landen
und wenn sie im herbst die zwölf euro
mindestlohn einführen dann wird ein
großer teil dieser erhöhung nicht bei
den arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
ankommen sondern wird beim finanzamt
landen und diese eigentlich wichtige
lohnzuwachs denn der ja auch
unterstützen das ist richtig das ist
diesen lohnzuwachs gibt aber der wird
mit ihrem unterlassen beim tarif dazu
führen dass es zu einem dicken
begrüßungsgeld beim fiskus kommt
die gesamten tarifeckwerte in der
einkommensteuer müssen angepasst werden
sie müssen nach rechts verschoben werden
sie wissen dass eigentlich und die eine
anpassung an die inflation die muss
jetzt erfolgen und nicht aus dem herbst
oder nächstes jahr oder jetzt muss die
anpassung erfolgen jetzt haben die
inflationsraten von knapp 8 prozent und
die erhöhung der werbungskosten des
werbungskosten pauschbetrag ist mit 1,7
milliarden ist ja eine ziemlich teure
gießkanne aber wie der sogenannten
energiepreis pauschale da wird nun
dieses gesetz tatsächlich zur farce denn
es wird zu einem belastungs gesetz für
arbeitgeber und die finanzverwaltung und
wenn sie sich ihr eigenes ziel vor augen
halten dass da war die kurzfristige und
soziale abfederung von herten aufgrund
der sprunghaft und drastisch gestiegenen
energiekosten wenn sie sich dieses
eigenen ziel vor augen halten dann
stellen sich doch drei fragen bei den
betroffenen erstens wieso leiten denn in
ihren augen nur die arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer an dieser gestiegenen
inflation und rentnerinnen und rentner
studentinnen und studenten bezieher von
lohnersatzleistungen den
versorgungsbezügen bleiben außen vor
zweitens die frage wenn die auszahlung
sowieso erst in einigen monaten kommt
warum wurde dann kein anderes verfahren
gewählt warum haben sie dieses
bürokratische die finanzverwaltung und
die arbeitgeber belastende
verfahren gewählt und zum dritten wieso
nehmen sie durch die sowieso schon
rechtlich fragwürdige besteuerung dieser
pauschale in kauf dass die
finanzverwaltung in einer flut
zusätzlicher arbeit erstickt das wird
übrigens zur folge haben dass 2023 im
frühjahr die bearbeitungsdauer beiden
steuererklärung noch länger dauert und
dass viele menschen in diesem land die
dringend auf die steuererstattung warten
und angewiesen sind da noch länger
warten müssen und entgegen deren
behauptungen werden es ja heute morgen
schon hinter debatte gehört entgegen
ihren behauptungen beteuerungen ist
diese regelung bei der energiepreis
pauschale eben nicht sozial ausgewogen
elterngeldbezieher junge familien
rentnerinnen rentner auch gerade mit
niedrigen renten studentinnen studenten
bleiben beim bezug außen vor und die
werden doch von den steigenden
energiepreisen mindestens genau so hart
getroffen wie alle anderen
die auszahlung so sie denn kommt sie
kommt zu spät wenig verdienende
minijobber und solo selbstständige
bekommen die energiepreis pauschale
frühestens im frühjahr 2023 ausbezahlt
nachdem sie eine steuererklärung
abgegeben haben für viele minijobber
bedeutet dass das erste mal dass
überhaupt eine steuererklärung abgeben
müssen um überhaupt an dieser
energiepreis pauschale zukommen und die
bekommen sie dann über ein jahr nachdem
wir heute diese debatte führen über ein
jahr müssen diese menschen auf die
entlastung warten heute führen wir die
debatte im mai 23 soll dann vielleicht
geld kommen wir werden jedenfalls dem
gesetzentwurf der ampel nach all dem
nicht zustimmen stattdessen bringen wir
einen eigenen entschließungsantrag ein
der aus drei elementen besteht erstens
kommen der umsetzung der steuertarif
jetzt an die hohe inflation anpassen
betonung oder jetzt anpassen wir
brauchen eine energiepreis pauschale für
alle bürgerinnen und bürger und wir
brauchen ein verfahren das wald
unbürokratischer ist als das was sie
hier heute vorgelegt haben vielen dank
olav gutting aus der unionsfraktion ist
überhaupt nicht einverstanden mit dem
was sowohl ampelkoalition als auch
wortgleich die bundesregierung hier
vorlegt zur steuerentlastung 20 22 und
jetzt kommt die gegenrede von michael
schrodi dem finanzpolitischen sprecher
der spd fraktion
steigende energiepreise durch den
angriffskrieg auch die ukraine und wir
brauchen den lieferketten durch die
pandemie
das sind die treiber der
preissteigerungen die besonders stark
bürgerinnen bürger mit kleinen mittleren
einkommen treffen deshalb bringen die
regierungsfraktionen umfangreiche
maßnahmen auf den weg die ganz gezielt
die belastungen abfedern sollen in der
expertenanhörung haben alles
sachverständiges paket begrüßt und dann
isoliert an manchen stellen gesagt dann
rät viermal und daran rädchen mal ich
möchte mal 1 verdeutlichen wir haben da
aus zahlreichen maßnahmen ein
gesamtpaket geschnürt mit über 30
milliarden euro ein riesiges paket zur
abfederung der
rundreise ein teil der nicht mehr drin
ist nicht nennen die eeg-umlage die wir
abschaffen die 200 euro grundsicherung
extrazahlung die vorher erst auf den weg
gebracht wurden neun
europäische energie steuersenkung
heizkostenzuschuss um mit diesen
entlastungsgesetz jetzt drehen wir 16
milliarden davon auf dem weg das sind
massive umfassende in dieser situation
aber notwendige und angemessene
maßnahmen die wir auf den weg bringen
und das kölner zunehmende erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags auf 1200 euro
und erhöhung der entfernungspauschale
für fernpendler 3 maßen damit ich noch
mal raus geben will weil sie zeigen dass
die maßnahmen ausgewogen sozial gerecht
sind und in der breite auch wirken wir
erhöhen den grundfreibetrag
rückwirkend zum 1 1 20 22 auf 10.300 47
euro übertragen euro erhöhung und das
wirkt für diejenige ist begonnen bayer
steuer
gleichmäßig es wirkt nicht so dass die
höchster einkauf meisten profitieren
soll das gleichmäßig entlastet wird was
wichtig ist dass wir eine kleine
mittleren einkommen hier profitieren
ähnlich wie beim kinderbonus ab juli 222
bekommt jede familie noch einmal 100
euro kinderbonus ähnlich wie auch in der
pandemie nicht auf die grundsicherung
angerechnet aber bei den freiwillig
kraft die höchsten einkommen ab
schmelzend das genau die ihn bekommen
die ihnen auch brauchen die mit kleinen
mittleren einkommen und wir sind dabei
mit der energiepreis pauschale
44 millionen
erwerbstätige in der bundesrepublik
deutschland direkt zu ergreifen meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren das sind
aber deren arbeitnehmer das sind
selbständige das sind aber auch mini
jobber übrigens auch der rentner die
rentnerin auch der studierende mit
minijob bekommt die energie preis kaufen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
allein das sind 13 milliarden euro die
wir auf den weg bringen und die
besteuerung darauf ist deswegen die
recht wohl höchste einkommen dann
weniger davon haben aber kleine
mittelrhein coolen mehr auch das ist
ausgewogen und sozial gerecht und wird
direkt auszahlen wie schnell der
unterstützung
und eine wenig beachtete aber wichtige
vereinbarung möchte ich schon noch mal
herausheben hier an der stelle in diesem
paket bis ende des jahres soll das
bundesfinanzministerium
eine lösung finden und uns vorlegen wie
wird die der auszahlungen einfacher
möglich machen können das gibt es bisher
nämlich nicht und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt wege finden wie wir diese
direktzahlungen an die bürgerinnen
bürger bringen zum beispiel indem wir
den kinderbonus mit dem kindergeld über
das kindergeld auszahlen und eins muss
ich schon sagen
mein dank gilt den fachbeamten
fachbeamten des finanzministeriums für
staatssekretärin auch in gilt mein dank
aber auch den
koalitionären hier wir haben es
geschafft das muss man doch anerkennen
dass wir eine aus zahlungsmöglichkeit
hinbekommen wirklich diese 44 millionen
menschen mit den 300 euro zu erreichen
und diese lösung für die auszahlung
einer gibt es pauschale dass bis auf
wenige ausnahmen alle die 300 euro im
september ausgezahlt bekommen
ist eine leistung und dann muss man auch
deutlich sagen auch vielen dank an die
arbeitgeber die wir da mit rein nehmen
die das mit auf den weg bringen müssen
alle auch geschafft haft weil sie nicht
in vorleistung gehen müssen dass sie
nicht vorfinanzieren müssen es ist
insgesamt eine leistung die wir auf den
weg gebracht haben in gemeinsamer arbeit
und deshalb ist das auch ein guter grund
dieses paket dieses 16 milliarden jetzt
mit einer breiten mehrheit in diesem
parlament auf den weg zu bringen die
menschen warten auf diese unterstützung
und sie werden von ampelkoalition genau
diese unterstützung bekommen die sie in
dieser situation auch noch
das war die sicht von michael schrodi
den finanzpolitischen sprecher der spd
fraktion nicht nur die ampel fraktionen
haben sich mühe gemacht mit diesem
steuerentlastungsgesetz auch die
oppositionsfraktionen haben einiges
zusammen geschrieben beispielsweise die
afg fraktion die hier zwei anträge
vorlegte einmal heißt ja
kraftstoffpreise senken wirtschaft
unterstützen und dann gibt es auch noch
einen entschließungsantrag aus der afg
fraktion zu diesem gesetzentwurf aber
mehr dazu jetzt von klaus stöber aus der
afg fraktion
komplizierter deutschland die
bürgerlichen die höhe da sterben mängel
sondern eben auch die transparenz und
die ungerechtigkeit die so viele
empfinden und der sechs monate bundestag
und ich denke mal ich kann inzwischen
wenn man die frage beantworten
das liegt wahrscheinlich daran dass
einige schon mehr als zwölf jahre im
bundestag sitzen und den bezug zur
realität verloren haben es liegt
vielleicht auch daran dass in den
fachausschüssen nicht unbedingt
fachleute sitzen was ja gar nicht
despektierlich gemeint ist sondern man
kann ja nicht erwarten dass in den
finanzausschuss 42 steuerexperten sitzen
ja was man erwarten kann ist dass
diejenigen sich zumindest an kundig
machen bei fachleuten und fachleute gibt
es ja es gibt es schönes zum ende der
öffentlichen hand höher und kollege
freddie da muss man schon eine ganz
dicke rosarote brille aufsetzen wenn man
den 1 begonnen hat dass die experten der
meinung waren dass war alles super
gesetzesvorschlag richtig ist auch und
nicht die qualität ist das genauso das
heißt eine sachverständigen zweifel
geäußert haben insbesondere an den
fahrer aus pauschale sie haben zweifel
geäußert ob der ebenfalls pauschal ab 11
kilometer gerecht ist sie haben zweifel
geäußert ob die drei cent die sie ab 21
kilometer gewähren ausreichen ist
angesichts der derzeit inflation und ich
hab das ja mal ein rhätischen bahn
geführt ich will nicht dass du mal sagen
bei 3000 euro brutto ja und 30
kilometern entfernung das sind das
gerade einmal 19 euro im jahr davon
wollen sie als entlastungsstrecke ist
lächerlich und
noch größer kritik gab es beim
energiepreis pauschal haben sie ja auch
als große erfindung der der koalition
dargestellt der bundesrepublik deutschen
arbeitgeberverbandes vier seiten
dargestellt dass ihr gesetzesentwurf
praktisch nicht umsetzbar ist ja und der
deutschen finanzgerichts tag ist nämlich
irgendjemand dass es jemand direkt zum
beispiel entscheidet darüber wenn jemand
klagt wenn jemand klagt
zwischen finanzamt und stoffen
entscheidet das heißt also leuten die
sich auskennen die sagen angesichts der
kompliziertheit diese ganzen
energiepreis pauschale empfehlen diese
diese steuerfrei direkt auszuzahlen
sachen deutsche finanz größte tageskasse
nachlesen der show die und
weise ihr kollege sind war ich heute
nicht da aber mit der energiepreis
pauschale könnten sie auch eine ganze
große bevölkerungsgruppe aus renten
werden überhaupt nicht bedacht dass in
21 millionen bürger die keine
energiepreis pauschale erhalte und
verließen 23 millionen zahlen jetzt
schon rund acht millionen bürger also
rentner starben wie so bekommen die
keine regiepreis pauschale
könnte man ja erwarten dass nach der
anhörung haben den vorschlägen der
experten dieser gesetzesentwurf
erarbeitet wird und vielleicht im keller
reform hier vorgestellt worden ist ist
nichts dergleichen
er selbst muss so wie es eingebracht war
und es hier auch beschlossen und das
denke ich mal ist das was die bürger
nicht verstehen können wenn man das
wenig einwendungen hat ihnen so ein
gesetz und fachleute sagen das ist nicht
umsetzbar und es auch nicht freundlicher
bürgern gegenüber dass trotzdem das eins
zu eins umgesetzt wird das geht so nicht
wir haben
die svp-fraktion eigenen gesetzesentwurf
eingebracht das sieht in are vor 40 cent
ab dem ersten kilometer das geht zum
beispiel auch für arbeitnehmer die nicht
darüber die möglichkeiten haben wird 100
euro für uns oben dem hubschrauber zur
arbeit zufrieden
nur bei den grundfreibetrag auf 12.600
euro erhöhen das was ich nicht nur die
kleine mittleren einkommen ihr klientel
als roadie entlasten sondern auch die
anzahl der steuerpflichtigen rentner
deutlich reduzieren die müssen jetzt
auch schon steuererklärung abgeben jedes
jahr werden 100.000 mehr so wir wollen
auch alle freibeträge und bausparkassen
hustons 29 inflationsbedingt angepassten
und direkt preis pauschale muss so
ausgestaltet werden dass ja praktisch
umsatzplus unserer sicht war sie am
besten umsetzbar weil sie steuerfrei
ausgezahlt wurde sie hatten die
möglichkeit fast ganz unkompliziert über
die studenten nummern über die
rententräger an die rentner an gestraft
hinaus zu zahlen des gesetzes konnte zum
schluss
dieser gesetzentwurf
entspricht nicht der realität wird es
wieder wegen den deswegen ab vielen dank
klaus stöber für die afg fragen zu
jetzt hat er noch etwas hinterher
gerufen aber das gehört nicht mehr zu
sagen debattenbeitrag nicht dass sie
meinen ich sei dem herrn ihr ins wort
gefallen klaus stöber aus seiner fdp
fraktion in der debatte zum
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 dem auch
der dieser debatte auch eine ganze reihe
anderer anträge vorlegen
dazu später mehr jetzt erstmal sascha
müller aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
so vieles zu den beiden entlastungs
paket der bundesregierung gesagt worden
auch hier im hohen haus der koalition
schafft zweierlei erstens entlasten wir
die breite der gesellschaft und zweitens
unterstützen wir dort besonders wo die
hohe oder überwiegend fossil getrieben
inflation besonders weh tut die
sachverständigen bewerteten tatsächlich
in unserer anhörung zum
steuerentlastungsgesetz der entlastungs
paket der koalition insgesamt als gut
und sind begrüßten die richtung die wir
damit gehen die ursprünglichen
gesetzentwurf hat mir bereits eine
erhöhung des grundfreibetrags eine
anhebung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrages
und eine zeitlich befristete höhere
pendlerpauschale verfährt pendler innen
vorgesehen mit dem entlastungspaket 2
nehmen wir nun auch noch zwei weitere
maßnahmen das gesetz auf erstens den
kinderbonus von 100 euro pro kind damit
bekommen speziell familien die
notwendige unterstützung und zweitens
natürlich die energiepreis pauschale für
erwerbstätige von 300 euro diese über
die einkommensteuer unterliegen das
bedeutet dass menschen mit geringem
einkommen am ende mehr davon haben als
menschen mit hohem einkommen und ja
diese energiepreis pauschale wurde er in
der anhörung zum gesetz besonders
intensiv diskutiert vor allem im blick
auf die ausgestaltung noch haben wir
keinen auszahlung mechanismus um den
bürgerinnen und bürgern direkte
zahlungen zukommen zu lassen aber wie
sie wissen liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen arbeitet die bundesregierung
daran dass so etwas in der zukunft zur
verfügung steht was sind gerade wir
grüne im wahlkampf mit dieser idee
kritisiert worden und jetzt machen wir
das als ampel regierung so geht gute und
vorausschauende politik nah am menschen
weil wir die
da wir die auszahlung allerdings derzeit
gezwungenermaßen noch für arbeitnehmer
innen auch über die arbeitgeberinnen
noch vornehmen mussten wir auch nach den
erkenntnissen der anhörung eine lösung
finden die auf arbeitgeberseite nicht zu
härten durch eine vorfinanzierung führt
und ich finde dass uns das sehr gut
gelungen ist und da schließe ich mich
den kollegen stroh die absolut an was
natürlich
was natürlich richtig ist
rentnerinnen und rentner bekommen diese
energiepreis pauschale ihre eigenschaft
als rentnerinnen und rentner nicht aber
wir haben sie nicht vergessen zahlreiche
andere entlastungsmaßnahmen kommen
rentnerinnen und rentnern zugute und
auch die 300 euro können unter umständen
renten haben und rentner erhalten und da
möchte ich noch kurz was dazu sagen was
mal kurz unter dem stichwort enkeltrick
durch die medienlandschaft ging ich
könne ja jedem renten hat jeder
rentnerin die sich etwas dazuverdienen
möchten oder auch dazu verdienen müssen
die 300 euro in diesem fall stehen diese
300 euro eben auch zu aber ich möchte
doch darauf hinweisen dass das
beschäftigungsverhältnis
selbstverständlich ernst gemeint sein
muss und die finanzbehörden das
sicherlich auch genau hinschauen werden
insgesamt
insgesamt ist uns als ampel davon bin
ich überzeugt ein rundes paket gelungen
jetzt liegt es abschließend dann am
bundesrat hier im bundestag bringen wir
dieses gesetz auch zur entlastung von
unserer seite auf den weg die menschen
baut in schwierigen zeiten auf uns und
sie können sich auf uns verlassen vielen
dank
sagte sascha müller aus der fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und ich habe schon
gesagt auch die anderen fraktionen
haben hier anträge eingebracht in diese
debatte über die entlastung von
bürgerinnen und bürger beispielsweise
die in linksfraktion hat zwei anträge
vorgelegt verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher vor energiepreissteigerungen
schützen und energiepreis explosion
ausgleichen mehr dazu von christian laie
dem wirtschaftspolitischen sprecher
schritte in die richtige richtung aber
es sind trippelschritte und sie reichen
nicht aus es ist richtig erwerbstätige
die steuerentlastung zu unterstützen
aber was ist mit denen die noch nicht
oder nicht mehr erwerbstätig sind wie
studierende und rentnerinnen und rentner
jeder fünfte mensch über 65 jahren ist
arm und einen rentner mit weniger als
900 euro im monat bekommt gerade mal
neun prozent der energie mehrkosten vom
staat zurück und jetzt frage ich sie
warum zum teufel kommt es wirklich in
jeder krise zu diesen politischen herten
gegenüber denen die am meisten auf
politische unterstützung
angewiesen sind vor den wahlen respekt
plakat in und nach dem ball 100
milliarden in die rüstung stecken aber
mit den älteren so umgehen so nicht
meine damen und herren
und gleichzeitig gehen die profite der
energiekonzerne durch die decke heute
hat shell den höchsten profit in der
geschichte seines unternehmens verkündet
und wir sagen im interesse der menschen
ist es unsere aufgabe dass wir hier
misstrauisch werden ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz müsste doch an
diese krisen gewinne dran gehen das wäre
gerecht meine damen und herren
und die regierung müsse jetzt handeln
bevor es zu schweren politischen
verwerfungen oder sogar zu sozialen
unruhen im land kommt und deswegen
beantragen wie auch dass die
energiepreise staatlich gedeckelt werden
dass es eine profit bremse gibt das wäre
gerecht meine damen und herren
und der punkt ist das hat es in
deutschland alles schon gegeben ludwig
erhard hat durch preiskontrollen und
profit bremsen die inflation gebremst
und gilt heute als vater der sozialen
marktwirtschaft was würden sie ihnen
denn heute sagen wenn er das gleiche
hier noch einmal versuchen würde und als
die energiepreise 1973 durch die decke
gingen da hat die bundesregierung im
energie sicherungs gesetzt höchstpreise
staatlich festzulegen das war damals
eine koalition aus spd und fdp also
quasi eine zweidrittel- ampel warum geht
das dann nicht bei einer ganzen ampel
und der witz ist genau dieses gesetz
wird in dieser woche im bundestag
diskutiert und die möglichkeit für
staatliche höchstpreise die steht da bis
heute drin sie müssen das nur anpassen
dann können wir das anbinden warum
machen wir das nicht
und die antwort auf diese rhetorische
frage ist ganz einfach weil die
interessen von kapital und konzernen
seit jahren vorfahrt in diesem hohen
hause haben man traut sich so was gar
nicht mehr und deswegen sagen wir an
dieser stelle in dieser inflation wird
es zu enteignung kommen entweder die
menschen da draußen zahlen durch
kaufkraftverlust oder man geht an die
profite der großen dran das ist die
politische frage um die es geht bitte
stimmen sie unserem antrag zum
dankeschön
christian neue der wirtschaftspolitische
sprecher der linksfraktion war das hier
geht es weiter um das
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20 22 und will
eine reihe von anträgen aus den
oppositionsfraktionen nächste rednerin
hier ist dagmar anderes aus der spd
fraktion ist mitglied im finanzausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen
zusammenfassend könnte man sagen wie man
es macht macht man es falsch dass eine
unterschiedliche wahrnehmung bei der
sachverständigenanhörung gibt ist ja
völlig klar natürlich konzentrieren sich
sowohl die sachverständige als auch die
fraktionen besonders gerne auf die
punkte die die eigene meinung
unterstützen die ausgestaltung der
einzelnen punkte ist diskutabel aber an
den fakten kommt man nun mal nicht
vorbei und fakt ist alle sachverständige
alle sachverständigen haben betont
dieses steuerentlastungsgesetz zu
begrüßen natürlich hätten manche
interessenvertreter gerne mehr es wäre
aber auch merkwürdig wenn alle
interessenvertreter ausnahmslos
zufrieden wären die kritik an der
auszahlungsmodalitäten der energiepreis
pauschale einerseits wird beklagt dass
die von uns gestellte art der auszahlung
zu spät käme andererseits wird aber
gleichzeitig ein neuer auszahlungsplan
ismus gefordert ja wer glaubt denn
bitteschön ernsthaft dass die auszahlung
schneller bei den menschen wäre wenn wir
uns jetzt noch zuerst auf dem neuen
ausstellungs mechanismus einigen müssen
richtig ist dass wir eine solche
vereinfachte art der direkt auszahlung
zukünftig brauchen für fälle wie zum
beispiel das klima geld richtig ist aber
auch dass die menschen jetzt
schnellstens diese energiepreis
pauschale erhalten sollen alle
arbeitnehmer alle mini jobber und alle
die auf ihre einkünfte einkommensteuer
vorauszahlungen leisten erhalten diese
energiepreis pauschale in höhe von 300
euro
spätestens im oktober
und ja es wird wenige menschen leben die
die energiepreise pauschale erst mit der
jahres veranlagung erhalten zum beispiel
bei arbeitgebern die ausschließlich
minijobber beschäftigen und trotzdem
können wir mit diesem system die meisten
menschen am schnellsten erreichen und
das ist uns wichtig
die kritik rentner und rentnerinnen und
studierende würden keine energiepreis
pauschale erhalten stimmt wenigstens
teilweise den rentnerinnen und
studierende mit erwerbstätigkeit wie zum
beispiel einem minijob erhalten
natürlich die energiepreis pauschale
rentnerinnen und studierende ohne
erwerbstätigkeit erhalten keine
energiepreis pauschale und nein wir
haben diese nicht vergessen wir wollen
mit dieser energiepreis pauschale
diejenigen unterstützen die durch die
höheren energiepreise mehr ausgeben
müssen um zur arbeit zu kommen
und weil rentner und studierende auch
unter den hohen energiekosten leiden
haben wir sie selbstverständlich mit
anderen maßnahmen berücksichtigt 9 euro
ticket abschaffen der eeg umlage senken
der energie steuer auf kraftstoffe
heizkostenzuschuss natürlich werden
diese personengruppen auch entlastet
aber eben nicht für einen weg zur arbeit
den sie gar nicht haben
das totschlagargument immer wieder gerne
angewandt bürokratie verwaltungsaufwand
ja stimmt alles was wir entscheiden
erzeugt verwaltungsaufwand wie sollst
dein bitte ohne verwaltung gehen die
verwaltung setzt um was hier geschlossen
wird und die folgen und die verwaltung
sorgt damit dafür dass die entlastung
genau da ankommt wo sie ankommen soll
und zwar genau in der höhe wie sie
ankommen soll und das wird hier
kritisiert
die hilfe sei nicht zielgerichtet wird
kritisiert das ist schlicht falsch
die ahnen es falsch die aufhörte zu
erklären auch warum anregungen die
anhebung des grundfreibetrags entlastet
alle relativ auch die personen mit
besonders kleinen einkommen mehr genau
das wollen wir der kinderbonus kommt
familien mit kindern zugute weil diese
von den gestiegenen energiepreisen
besonders hart getroffen wurden aber
durch die verrechnung mit dem
kinderfreibetrag haben familien mit
geringem einkommen mehr von diesem
kinderbonus als die gut und besser
verdienenden genau das wollen wir die
erhöhung des arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags
reduziert den verwaltungsaufwand und
stellt für rund zwei drittel der
angestellten beschäftigten arbeitnehmer
in eine verbesserung dar das wollen wir
abgeordnete erlauben sie also zwischen
frage von der afg danke aber nein danke
die erhöhen das hatte schon die
energiepreise
in höhe von 300 euro wird mit dem
individuellen steuersatz besteuert und
das bedeutet dass personen mit geringem
einkommen mehr von dieser energiepreis
pauschale haben als die gut und besser
verdienenden und genau das wollen wir
alles in allem wurde dieses
steuerentlastungsgesetz von allen
sachverständigen grundsätzlich positiv
bewertet diese über 30 milliarden kommen
zielgerichtet dort an wo sie ankommen
sollen und das ist ein sehr gutes gesetz
wie man's macht macht man es falsch aber
der größte fehler wäre dieses gesetz
nicht dieses gesetz nicht zu beschließen
vielen dank
starkem anderes aus der spd fraktion
vertritt natürlich den koalitionsentwurf
der wie gesagt wortgleich ist mit einem
entwurf aus der bundesregierung und
jetzt gibt es eine kurzintervention von
kai gottschalk aus der fdp fraktion
auch nicht in der anhörung mein kollege
stöger hat eben ja gesagt wenn man
vielleicht keine ahnung hat dann sollte
man sich wenigstens ein arbeit erst neun
euro ticket japan sind es zu lachen ist
befristet auf 3 0 drei monate das heißt
sie unterstellen wahrscheinlich das sind
drei monaten dann wieder alles in der
energiewelt und der inflation in ordnung
sein 2 und ist sie hier als wohltat
verkaufen nämlich den grundfreibetrag
anzuheben dazu sehen sie nach
verfassungsgerichtlichen urteil
verpflichtet nämlich das existenzminimum
freizustellen und alle ich betone alle
sachverständigen in der anhörung haben
ausdrücklich betont dass diese anhebung
die sie jetzt angeblich großzügig
vornimmt jetzt schon nicht die erreichte
inflationsrate wird ausgleichen ist das
heißt da werden sie nachlegen müssen
selbst der dgb angesagt in dieser
anhörung dass sie die anhebung für nicht
angemessen halten lieben sie da in einer
parallelwelt an dieser stelle
desweiteren verschweigen sie dass sie
doch für die energiekosten und den
anstieg verantwortlich sind sie treten
reden von einer faszinierenden fraktion
fahren sie zum einmal in die
europäischen nachbarländer und sie haben
vergessen dass sie festgelegt haben 25
euro pro tonne co2 ab 21 30 euro pro co2
in diesem jahr 35 euro 45 euro und gar
55 euro im jahr 2025 ihre regierung ihre
politik sind die größten preistreiber
hier im bereich der energie das sollten
sie vielleicht den menschen nach oben
mal sagen ganz zu schweigen von innere
ihrer energie steuer ganz darauf zu
tragen dass sie mehr einnahmen von mehr
als einer mio der euro bei den
gestiegenen energiepreisen auf sprit
haben und da noch zu sagen dieser
sogenannte
heizkostenzuschuss das zeigt ihre
ahnungslosigkeit der soll den menschen
zugute kommen die pendel das sagen sie
mal ein händler der offenen land wohnt
er auch einkaufen muss also bitte sie
leben wirklich in einer parallelwelt
ohne ahnung haben sie nicht tut mir leid
möchten sie erwidern bitteschön
also erstens sollten sie hier keine
unterstellungen machen sondern sich
ausschließlich auf das beziehen was ich
auch wirklich gesagt haben dass nicht
das was sie mal den gehört zu haben
zweitens haben sie jetzt gerade wieder
überzeugend dargestellt dass ihre
ansichten und aussagen durchaus
unterirdisch sind und meistens zum
fremdschämen
drittens der existenzminimum bericht von
dvd von ihm erwähnt wurde der kommt im
oktober und wir haben schon im vorfeld
die inflationsrate mit dem um das
ausgleichen der progression der kalten
progression angepasst
was sie hier gerade gemacht haben wie
sie es immer machen sie nehmen einzelne
einzelpunkte raus aus einem gesamtpaket
und achten mal wieder nicht den gesamten
zusammenhang das ist
populismus oder oder dank für den
hinweis oder man kann es auch so sagen
die intelligenz ist woanders einfach
breiter gestreut danke
da sind wir jetzt kurz vor ende der
debatte da geht es auf einmal noch mal
mächtig hoch her im deutschen bundestag
aber es geht ja auch um das
steuerentlastungsgesetz unter schauen
vielleicht auch noch mal ein paar mehr
menschen zu und da kann man natürlich
die eigenen position hier und da noch
mal ein klein wenig deutlicher machen
sebastian brehm islam pohl sprecher
finanzen und haushalt der
csu-landesgruppe zu diesem gesetz der
name des gesetzes ist irreführend sie
sagen es ist ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz
2022 sie gleichen nicht einmal die
teuerungsrate aus dem jahr 2021 aus ganz
geschweige denn dass die inflation und
die bewegung aus 2022 mit diesem gesetz
überhaupt keine berücksichtigung findet
haben heute früh darüber diskutiert die
erhöhung des grundfreibetrags machen sie
aber sie ändern die tarifeckwerte nicht
das heißt ab der zweiten stufe sozusagen
im steuertarif geht es wesentlich
steiler sodass letztlich bei den 300
euro bonus letztlich die inflation und
die kalte progression zuschlägt ich
komme dann später noch mal drauf der
zweite punkt auch bei der
entfernungspauschale man muss schon
fairerweise mal sagen dass in der
anhörung nahezu alle sachverständigen
selbst werfe dgb dieses gesetz
kritisiert haben und gesagt haben es
kommt nicht zielgerichtet genug an ein
punkt war die entfernungspauschale 80
prozent aller pendlerinnen und pendler
fahren unter 20 kilometer und haben
natürlich auch mehrkosten die
berücksichtigen sie überhaupt nicht
zweite ist das was sie zurückgeben an
die bürgerinnen und bürger ist viel zu
wenig wenn sie die einnahmen aktuell aus
den steuern beträgen nehmen allein aus
der umsatzsteuer im ersten quartal
dieses jahres haben wir eine erhöhung
von 34,3 prozent 20 milliarden euro
alleine aus der umsatzsteuer wenn man
noch die einkommensteuer zunimmt mit
17,3 prozent steigerung dann haben wir
einen wesentlich höhere einnahmen beim
staat als das was sie an die bürgerinnen
und bürger jetzt zurückgeben müssten
deswegen ist es eben kein
steuerentlastungsgesetz sondern ein
steuerbelastung gesetz liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und drittens
[Applaus]
drittens
das was sie wenigstens geben
ist so kompliziert und so bürokratisch
also sowas haben wir selten erlebt das
einkommensteuergesetz hat 111 artikel
111 paragrafen sie fügen jetzt achtung
sie fügen jetzt für eine 300 euro
einmalige pauschale 11 ganze paragrafen
ins einkommensteuergesetz mit 1 11 stück
sind 10 vom einkommensteuergesetz für
eine einmalige auszahlung extrem
kompliziert und dann ist auch noch diese
energiepreis pauschale brutto das heißt
dem steuereinnahmen werden beim staat ja
noch mehr weil von dem was sie an die
bürgerinnen und bürger geben holen sie
gleich die steuer ab liebe kollegen
natürlich stimmt es ist natürlich otto
schauen sie doch in ihren eigenen
gesetzen wird
also man hätte wirklich eine eigene eine
einfachere auszahlung machen können und
auch netto auszahlung machen können weil
wenn man mal berechnet man kriegt eine
energiepreis pauschale von 300 euro dann
zahlen wir die zahlen die bürgerinnen
und bürger die steuer drauf dann bleiben
vielleicht 160 170 euro übrig durch die
kalte progression die zuschlägt bleiben
vielleicht knapp 100 euro übrig die an
die bürgerinnen und bürger ausgezahlt
werden und die belastung ist aber 56 700
euro für eine familie und apropos
familien
sie lassen diejenigen aus diesem gesetz
heraußen die eigentlich die energiepreis
pauschale dringend bräuchten studenten
bekommen sie nicht
rentnerinnen und rentner bekommen sie
nicht und junge familien die elterngeld
beziehen bekommen sie auch nicht das ist
wirklich skandalös liebe kolleginnen
sie machen
studenten rentnerinnen und rentner
familien zum blinden fleck in der
inflationspolitik so geht's nicht
deswegen haben wir auch heute an den
änderungsantrag vorbereitet und sie
können dokumentieren ob sie dazu stehen
alle menschen in diesem land zu
entlasten dann müssten sie unserem
antrag zustimmen wenn sie nicht
zustimmen sagen sie ein klares nein zu
den studenten sagen sie ein klares nein
zu den rentnerinnen und rentnern und
sagen sie ein klares nein zu den jungen
familien die elterngeld beziehen diese
regel keine energiepreis pauschale sie
werden mehr belastet durch kalte
progression sie werden mehr belastet
durch inflation sie nehmen den menschen
genau die die es brauchen das geld weg
und machen keine entlastungen im
haushalt und letztlich muss man einst
noch sagen die mehreinnahmen wissen sie
wo sie hingehen wir gehen in den
haushalt zu schaffen
3433 neue stellen in den ministerien und
in den verwaltungen geht aus der anfrage
von uns hervor dort ist das geld
vergraben die bürgerinnen und bürger
bräuchten dieses geld dringend geben sie
es ihnen zurück herzlichen dank
sebastian brehm aber das haushalts- und
finanzpolitische sprecher der csu
landesgruppe im deutschen bundestag wir
sind bei den letzten redner den
angekommen in dieser debatte und dann
gibt es eine ganze reihe von
abstimmungen gleich aber erst hören
würden auch katharina beck die
finanzpolitische sprecherin der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen
und das ist schon fast unredlich
lieberherr bremen mit dem kinderbonus
entlasten gesetz reden auch familien und
das muss ich einfach auch mal gesagt
werden
die union bot mir ist jetzt zum
abschluss dieses gesetzes noch mal ein
punkt ganz wichtig die hohen kosten vor
allem für fossile energien die treiben
natürlich die preise nach oben wir haben
heute morgen ausführlichst und groß über
inflation gesprochen wir wissen auch und
wir entlasten die menschen mit
milliardenbeträgen vieles ist gesagt
worden und wird rüde tragen sogar
maßnahmen mit um die menschen zu
entlasten die uns vielleicht nicht so
gut gefallen zum beispiel eben die
genannte erhöhung der fern
pendlerpauschale die ist nämlich nicht
unbedingt jetzt klima positiv aber wir
sind eine sozial-ökologische
regierung und wir möchten hier eben auch
da die entlastungen zur verfügung stehen
und ich möchte aber jetzt doch noch
einmal auf punkte eingehen wir sind
nämlich nicht nur reaktiv mit unseren
gesetzen sondern wir sind auch
vorausschauend zb bei der
pendlerpauschale
die wollen wir nämlich das haben wir
auch vereinbart sozial und ökologisch
weiterentwickeln und die relevanz ist
uns doch vor wenigen tagen noch mal vor
augen geführt worden 1,5 grad dieser
krasse kipp punkt der klimakatastrophe
kann schon in den nächsten fünf jahren
eintreten und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass wir jetzt vorausschauend unsere
instrumente weiterentwickeln
das ist total erschreckend und ich
möchte einmal noch mal auf die
flutkatastrophe eingeben was das auch
finanziell für auswirkungen hat
natürlich menschlich und sozial das war
ja nicht zu ertragen und ist es auch
immer noch nicht in den regionen in
nordrhein westfalen und rheinland pfalz
aber eben auch wirtschaftlich und
finanziell ist das eine katastrophe
wir reden hier gerade über ein
steuerentlastungsgesetz und es geht um
finanzen und haushalt und dieser
wiederaufbau von den wir für die
betroffenen regionen kreiert haben
enthält 30 milliarden euro das ist
absolut notwendig aber das bedeutet auch
umgerechnet dass jede und jeder in
diesem land trotz 360 euro dazu zu geben
hat das ist also mehr als die energie
press pauschale die wir jetzt aus seine
das zeigt aber auch klimaschutz
wenn wir das richtig machen dann können
wir nämlich solche ausgaben in zukunft
verhindern und deswegen schützt uns das
vor zukünftigen belastungen und deswegen
ist auch hier die ökologische
weiterentwicklung
der pendlerpauschale und anderer
maßnahmen einfach ein ganz essentieller
bestandteil auch unseres gesetzespakets
der noch nicht so prominent gesagt wurde
aber es wirklich wichtig ist
und dazu gehört auch das geplante klima
bereit für alle bürgerinnen und bürger
um hohe co2 kosten auszugleichen
bei der energiepreis pauschale es ist
schon etwas dran da ist es noch etwas
kompliziert die auszahlungen zu
organisieren das können wir halt einfach
heute mit unseren rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen noch nicht so gezielt
aber um das beim klima geld besser
hinzubekommen haben wir im jetzigen
paket auch einen zweiten sehr
vorausschauenden punkt nämlich
vereinbart dass wir einen einfachen und
unbürokratischen weg für direktzahlungen
auf den weg bringen und das ist richtige
politik dieses gesetzespaket entlastet
jetzt hat aber auch vorausschauende
elemente und das ist kluge politik wie
ich sie mir von dieser regierung wünsche
und wie ich sie auch mitgestalten kann
darüber freue ich mich mit ihnen allen
zusammen und herzlichen dank für dieses
tolle gesetzt
ich schließe die aussprache vielen dank
für die engagierte diskussion und wir
kommen nun zur abstimmung über den von
den fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp
eingebrachten entwurf eines
steuerentlastungsgesetzes
2022 der finanzausschuss empfiehlt unter
buchstabe a seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache 17 65 den gesetzentwurf
der fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp auf drucksache 13 33 in der
ausschuss fassung anzunehmen ich bitte
diejenigen die dem gesetzentwurf in der
ausschuss fassung zustimmen wollen um
das handzeichen wer stimmt dafür
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp wäre
stimmt dagegen dass es die cdu csu wir
enthält sich die afg und die linke damit
ist der gesetzentwurf in zweiter
beratung angenommen dritte beratung und
schlussabstimmung ich bitte diejenigen
die dem gesetzentwurf zustimmen wollen
sich zu erheben
das ist wieder die spd bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp vielen dank wer stimmt
dagegen
ankommen das schaffen sie schon
aufzustehen dann ein bisschen müde
cdu/csu vielen dank wer enthält sich
ja ich warte auch auf den letzten genau
fast die afg fraktion und die linke
damit ist der gesetzentwurf auch in
dritter lesung angenommen wir kommen zur
abstimmung über die
entschließungsanträge
abstimmung über den entschließungsantrag
der fraktionen der cdu/csu auf
drucksache 17
78 wer stimmt für diesen
entschließungsantrag
das ist die cdu csu wer stimmt dagegen
das sind spd bündnis 90 die grünen und
die fdp während hält sich afg und linke
der entschließungsantrag ist somit
abgelehnt und diesem
entschließungsantrag ging es unter
anderem darum einen
einkommensteuertarife über den
grundfreibetrag hinaus an die hohe
inflation anzupassen also viel weiter zu
gehen in der in der reform von
steuerlichen maßnahmen wir sind jetzt
beim entschließungsantrag der fdp
fraktion die im kern von allem etwas
mehr gerne hätte als das was jetzt im
steuerentlastungsgesetz gerade
beschlossen worden ist also
beispielsweise eine höhere
entfernungspauschale und einen höheren
grundfreibetrag ähnliche dinge von allem
etwas mehr auch dass es hier abgelehnt
worden mit der mehrheit des hauses sind
wir an den einzelnen thematischen
anträgen die jedem noch zur diskussion
gestanden haben alle fraktionen im hause
gegenprobe enthaltung damit ist das
einstimmig angenommen also die
beschlussempfehlung ist einstimmig
angenommen tagesordnungspunkt 14b
beschlussempfehlung des ausschusses für
klimaschutz und energie zu dem antrag
der fraktion die linke mit dem titel
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher vor
energie preissteigerung schützen der
ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 10 96
den antrag der fraktion die linke auf
drucksache
682 abzulehnen wer stimmt für diese
beschlussempfehlung
das ist die spd bündnis 90 die grünen
fdp cdu csu und fdp stimmt dagegen das
ist die linke er enthält sich niemand
die beschlussempfehlung ist mit großer
mehrheit angenommen und mit der annahme
der beschlussempfehlung ist eben der
antrag der linksfraktion in diesem fall
abgelehnt weil er auch schon im
zuständigen ausschuss abgelehnt worden
war
das ist die linke wer stimmt dagegen
das sind alle übrigen fraktionen
enthaltung entsprechend keine der antrag
ist mit großer mehrheit abgelehnt
zusatzpunkt sechs beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für klimaschutz und
energie zu dem antrag der fraktion der
afg mit dem titel
kraftstoffpreise senken wirtschaft
unterstützen wirtschaftskrise verhindern
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 10 93
den antrag der fraktion der afd auf
drucksache 707 abzulehnen wer stimmt für
diese beschlussempfehlung
dass es die linke spd bündnis 90 die
grünen fdp und cdu/csu wer stimmt
dagegen das ist die afg enthaltung keine
die beschlussempfehlung ist mit großer
mehrheit angenommen